so today's messages for those of you
that account on the fence let me explain
to what I mean by that you kind of want
to give everything you got to whatever
you're doing right now but you don't you
kind of know you need to get reading and
find a way to improve but you don't you
know you need to change some of your
associations and friendships but you
don't you know you've got to drop some
bad habits alcohol pot drugs but you
don't you know you've kind of got to get
in the game and get focused but you
don't so the question becomes why don't
you why
now many will say belief is one of them
I don't because I just don't believe in
myself mmm okay
let's say that's one of them but there's
got to be another one and here's one for
many of you here's what it is it's very
simple it's something we think about but
we never talk about here's what it is
ready is it worth it is it worth it
what do you mean pad it's the question
you ask yourself that nobody hears it's
it really worth it me reading these
hundred books or 200 books I don't know
if it works or not because some kind of
social media said he never reads books
it is it worth it for me to work that
hard because I heard a relative man he
died young from working very hard is it
worth it is it worth it for me to really
drop all my friends and all these guys
because I go way back with them I've
read some stuff in poetry and scripture
says you know you got to kind of stay
grounded to the people they you grew up
with you know is it worth it to drop all
these drugs and all this other stuff I
heard a lot of good things about drugs
is it worth it you know salic is a big
deal if I drink alcohol everybody drinks
uccle so worth it
is it worth it for me to go out and work
very hard and really get focused and
give five to ten years what if I have to
ten years from that doesn't happen see
those the questions you ask yourself
because life is about odds and you're
betting on the fact that it's not going
to happen to you so because of that you
don't give everything and you create
whatever you have in your mind that
won't happen it's like I don't know if
it's gonna work out
for me what if this happen what if that
happens what if this happens and it's
like a salesperson you are such an
incredible salesperson for those of you
that don't give everything because you
don't know if it's worth it you sold
yourself so well on the fact that it's
not worth it you've sold yourself again
no one sees it every time you sell
yourself in that moment you know when it
happens to stop and listen to how you're
selling yourself and the trick is to try
to trick your mind and selling yourself
on the other way believe me you're
talking to a guy that didn't like to
work hard you're talking to a guy that
hated reading books miss Collins always
bullied me when he came down to reading
hey Beth David I would sit next to this
girl named Carmen she was a cheerleader
and I would try to hide behind her
Patrick read the next paragraph no clue
how to read governament eslint
said of island wetness day this is this
guy I hated reading I don't want to drop
my friends I love my old friends going
to parties I still love them till today
I miss them till today but what am I
gonna do go to nightclubs and just kind
of get distracted they're not gonna pay
my bills that's not their
responsibilities is my responsibilities
drugs alcohol I partied hardcore in the
army every week I drank tequila every
single week we would compete who can
drink 26 beers a night that's army days
what the hell am I gonna do doing that
kind of stuff don't want to do it so is
it worth it it's a tough question and
only 1% can answer that I'm giving you
my testimony so how many other people
you have to believe the side that gave
everything they had are you gonna
believe the side that didn't give
everything they had and they never
achieved that side and so they can only
talk from one standpoint which is those
who never give it all and they think
it's worth it even though they have no
clue what it is if they would have given
it all and I'm telling you from both
sides I was a guy that didn't give it
all and it wasn't worth it life was very
boring and I gave it all and I went
through all that process and I can't
even tell you the experience won't
become and obviously my life is just
starting this is just the beginning but
as you go about your day today ask
yourself two question when you get when
you're done watching this video ask
yourself huh
think about that man how does this guy
know what I'm thinking about right now
maybe I am thinking about that right now
maybe I got to share this with my wife
my husband my boyfriend girlfriend you
know that's crazy we're just talking
about this is it worth it I'm hoping you
lean towards realizing it's worth it
because the pain of you not giving
everything now is even ten times more
painful than today given at five years
ten years is not a big deal
living would regress for 56 years as
painful 40 years very painful dying with
a lot of regrets that's painful that's
painful
most people go like that just so you
know the conversation when your daughter
is 32 years old mature and she's over
the fact that you were her idol and she
loved you and she's Contour mature phase
the mature phase then she's married with
kids and one day you guys are just
having conversation saying daddy having
me don't work hearted that what was it
what were you afraid of
that's a tough conversation you may not
be thinking about it right now cuz
you're only 32 years old but you'll be
68 in no time all of us will and some of
those conversations are coming that's
just life I'm not trying to make you
think negative positive anything I just
want you to get a little tough and
realizing you have to make the decision
whether it's worth it or not I'm just
one human being in your life that's
telling you this price is worth more
than the price of avoiding it and I hope
you make the right choice anyways have a
great day today